OK. Take a second right now and just think about this. When it comes to the big hot button issues-- I mean climate change, and gun control, and abortion rights, and school vouchers, and affirmative action, and Obamacare-- OK. Do you know anybody who has changed their minds? Who firmly was on one side of the issue, and then they read a story in The New York Times or they heard something on Rush Limbaugh, and now they are firmly on the other side? I'm just going to guess. Probably not, right?
好了。现在花一秒钟好好思考一下。当谈到那些热门的大问题时——我是说气候变化、枪支管制、堕胎权、学校代金券、平权行动和奥巴马医改——好吧，你认识任何改变过主意的人吗？谁曾经坚定地站在问题的某一边，然后读了《纽约时报》的一篇文章或听了拉什·林博（Rush Limbaugh）的节目，现在就坚定地站在了另一边？我猜，大概没有，对吧？
In fact, the opposite happens. There's this thing called the backfire effect. It's been documented in all kinds of studies. It shows that when we're confronted with evidence disapproving what we believe, generally we just dig in and we believe it more. And the rare times that people do change, it's slow. You don't just have an argument with your uncle over the invasion of Iraq over dinner, and then at the end of dinner, one of you goes, OK, I no longer believe what I did, you're right. People just don't flip like that, which is why this video is so incredible.
事实上，恰恰相反。有一种现象叫“逆火效应”（backfire effect）。各种研究都记录了这一点。它表明，当我们面对否定我们信仰的证据时，通常我们只会更加坚持，更加相信原本的观点。而人们确实改变的罕见时刻，过程也非常缓慢。你不会在晚餐时为了伊拉克战争的问题和叔叔争论，然后晚餐结束时，你们其中一人说：“好吧，我不再坚持以前的看法了，你是对的。”人们不会那样轻易转变，这就是为什么这段视频如此不可思议。
Hello.
你好。
Hello, sir.
你好，先生。
OK. So there are two men standing in a driveway. There's a canvasser with a clipboard. And he's talking to a California voter about gay marriage and it's 2013. And the voter leans against his truck for a lot of the conversation. He tells the canvasser that on a scale of zero to 10, where 10 is definitely vote for gay marriage and zero is definitely vote against, he's a five.
好的。现在有两个男人站在车道上。有个带着剪贴板的拉票员。他在2013年和一位加州选民谈论同性婚姻。在大部分谈话过程中，这位选民都靠在他的卡车上。他告诉拉票员，如果以0到10打分，10分代表绝对支持同性婚姻，0分代表绝对反对，他给自己打5分。
You know-- you know what bothers me is gays that are flaming. Flaming are the ones that are just so damn goofy and all that.
你知道——让我困扰的是那些娘娘腔的同性恋。那种举止非常轻浮、极其做作的人。
He sort of flips his wrist as he says this.
他一边说，一边甩了甩手腕。
I worked with one for probably like five or 10 years. He was my father's wife's brother. And I didn't even know he was gay. But he was just really-- he had five sisters. And I just thought he was feminine. And finally he came out and he said he was gay. When they act like that-- to me, I don't care if they do it to other people-- but don't do it to me. Because I don't-- you know.
我和一个这样的人共事了大约五到十年。他是我父亲妻子的兄弟。我甚至不知道他是同性恋。他只是非常——他有五个姐妹。我只觉得他很女性化。最后他出柜了，承认自己是同性恋。当他们表现成那样时——对我来说，我不在乎他们怎么对待别人——但别对我那样。因为我——你知道的。
At the same time, this guy says, he thinks it's only fair that gay people get the benefits of marriage, and they can get on their partner's insurance. And he knows other people who are gay that are perfectly nice, even that flaming guy. Perfectly nice. They're just regular people, he says. They talk for 18 minutes.
与此同时，这家伙说，他认为同性恋者获得婚姻福利、可以加入伴侣的保险是公平的。他也认识其他同性恋者，他们人很好，甚至那个娘娘腔的家伙也是。他们非常好。他说，他们只是普通人。他们谈了18分钟。
And the guy with the clipboard-- he's not a pollster. He's been sent out specifically to change people's minds on this issue. To try to flip them into voting for gay marriage. And so part of the conversation is just about the issue itself, like the pros and cons of gay marriage. Does the voter think it'll have a bad effect on children? What are his concerns about it? The voter explains.
那个拿着剪贴板的人——他不是民意调查员。他是被专门派来改变人们在这个问题上的看法的。试图让他们转而投票支持同性婚姻。因此，部分谈话是关于问题本身，比如同性婚姻的利弊。这位选民是否认为这会对孩子产生不良影响？他对此有什么担忧？选民做了解释。
The religious thing would hold me back a little bit. Just because.
宗教因素会让我有些顾虑。仅仅是因为。
OK.
好的。
I believe in God strongly. And I believe in his ways.
我坚定地信仰上帝。我信仰他的道。
But a lot of the conversation is just them talking in this totally honest way about themselves, and their attitudes about homosexuality, and the voter's experiences with homosexuals. The canvasser-- his name is Richard Joludow-- is gay himself. Not flamboyant gay, by the way. Silver hair, goatee, a contractor in the construction business. And here's just how real and free-floating this conversation is. At one point, the voter feels comfortable enough to ask him--
但大部分谈话只是他们以一种完全诚实的方式谈论自己，谈论他们对同性恋的态度，以及这位选民与同性恋者相处的经历。拉票员——他的名字叫理查德·乔卢多（Richard Joludow）——他自己就是个同性恋。顺便说一句，他不是那种张扬的同性恋。留着银发和山羊胡，是个建筑承包商。这就是对话如何真实且自由地展开。在某个时刻，选民感到足够自在，便问他——
At what point did you realize you were gay? How does a child realize they're gay?
你是在什么时候意识到自己是同性恋的？孩子怎么意识到自己是同性恋的？
You know, that's a hard-- I could think back to third grade. And I had a crush on a boy in the class. And it wasn't sexual. I didn't know what that was. But I can still remember kind of what he looks like. I'm pretty sure I remember his name still. And I remember being heartbroken when he left early in the first part of the semester there.
你知道，这很难——我可以回想起三年级的时候。我当时暗恋班上的一个男孩。那不是性的冲动。我不知道那是什么。但我仍然记得他长什么样。我很确定我还能记得他的名字。我记得当他在学期前半段提早离开时，我感到心碎。
And some people think that being gay is a choice. I was talking with a voter and was telling me he thought it was a choice. And I said my choice was to accept being gay. And of course, I tried to be straight. And that just wasn't working.
有些人认为同性恋是一种选择。我曾和一个选民交谈，他告诉我他认为这是一种选择。我说，我的选择是接受自己是同性恋。当然，我也尝试过做直男。但这根本行不通。
Well, yeah. If it doesn't work, it doesn't work. [LAUGHS]
嗯，是的。如果行不通，就是行不通。（笑）
And then at that point, the canvasser, Richard, very skillfully brings them back to the topic at hand.
在那一点上，拉票员理查德非常巧妙地把谈话带回了当前的话题。
So your vote has a lot of influence on how my life goes. I'm with somebody now that I'm hoping to get engaged or go and have a full-out marriage. So your vote would be very important to-- it would affect my life.
所以你的投票对我的生活有很大影响。我现在有一个伴侣，我希望订婚或去结婚。所以你的投票对我来说非常重要——它会影响我的生活。
Your life and a lot of other people, too.
你的生活，还有许多其他人的生活。
That's correct, that's correct.
没错，没错。
That's a lot to think about, too. Cause after meeting you, you're a hell of a nice guy.
那也确实值得深思。因为见到你之后，你真是个很好的人。
Thanks.
谢谢。
Then Richard asked the voter for a second time, OK, on a scale of zero to 10, what's the chance that he would vote for gay marriage? His answer the first time was five. Now it's eight. Barely 14 minutes have passed.
然后理查德第二次问这位选民，好的，按0到10的比例，他投票支持同性婚姻的可能性有多大？第一次他的回答是5。现在是8。距离谈话开始仅仅过去了14分钟。
You make a really good presentation.
你讲得真好。
Thank you, sir.
谢谢你，先生。
And even more amazing than the fact that this actually worked is that it lasted. Richard was part of an army of hundreds of volunteers around Los Angeles who were sent out to change people's minds. And a study by researchers at UCLA and Columbia University found that a year later, not only did these voters stay convinced, they also convinced others in their own households to switch. Apparently neither of those things ever happens.
比这实际上奏效了更让人称奇的是，这种转变持续了下来。理查德是洛杉矶周围数百名志愿者大军的一员，他们被派去改变人们的想法。加州大学洛杉矶分校和哥伦比亚大学的研究人员进行的一项研究发现，一年后，这些选民不仅保持了观点，还说服了他们家庭中的其他人也转而支持。显然，这两种情况通常都不会发生。
From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today on our radio program, in this world where it is incredibly rare for anyone to change their minds, we have three stories about the very infrequent instances where that does happen, where people change their minds over fundamental things that they believe. Why does it happen in these particular unusual circumstances? We explain. Stay with us.
这是WBEZ芝加哥电台的《美国生活》（This American Life）。我是艾拉·格拉斯（Ira Glass）。在今天的广播节目中，在这个人们极少改变想法的世界里，我们有三个关于这种情况确实发生的罕见案例的故事，讲述人们如何改变了他们深信不疑的根本事物。为什么这些不同寻常的情况会发生？我们会做出解释。请继续收听。
And let's just keep going with this story. This story is Act One, which we're calling Do Ask, Do Tell.
让我们继续这个故事。这个故事是第一幕，我们称之为“问吧，说吧”（Do Ask, Do Tell）。
Where that video you just heard came from was a very unusual campaign to change voters' minds in California. And the campaign came about because of desperation. It was created in the wake of the 2008 election. And you may remember one of things on the ballot in that election was California's Proposition 8, Prop 8. At the time, gay marriage was officially legal in California-- had been legal for half a year. Then opponents of gay marriage gathered signatures, put the issue on the ballot. Not the gay organizers were worried-- in fact, anything but. Polls had them solidly ahead.
你刚才听到的那段录音来自一场在加州改变选民想法的非常规运动。这场运动是因为绝望而产生的。它是在2008年选举之后创建的。你可能记得那次选举选票上的内容之一是加州的第8号提案（Prop 8）。当时，同性婚姻在加州是正式合法的——已经合法半年了。随后，同性婚姻的反对者收集了签名，将该议题列入选票。同性恋组织者们并不担心——事实上，恰恰相反。民意调查显示他们遥遥领先。
Hey, liberal, progressive California. This is a no-brainer. And we lost.
嘿，自由进步的加州。这本来是毫无疑问的。但我们输了。
Steve Deline is a field organizer with the Leadership LAB at the Los Angeles LGBT Center, which is a very large multimillion-dollar nonprofit, the biggest LGBT organization in the world.
史蒂夫·德莱恩（Steve Deline）是洛杉矶LGBT中心“领导实验室”（Leadership LAB）的现场组织者，这是一个非常庞大的数百万美元的非营利组织，也是世界上规模最大的LGBT组织。
We lost by a decent margin. And it was devastating. Because everyone in California and beyond expected us to win that election.
我们以相当大的差距输掉了。这太令人崩溃了。因为加州乃至其他地方的每个人都以为我们会赢得那次选举。
People were shocked and angry and despairing.
人们感到震惊、愤怒和绝望。
That's Dave Fleischer. He's a political operative that the Los Angeles LGBT Center flew in to figure out what in the world they were going to do after this defeat. It was his idea to go out and do something that apparently is just never done.
那是戴夫·弗莱彻（Dave Fleischer）。他是一位政治操盘手，洛杉矶LGBT中心请他来弄清楚在这次失败后他们到底该怎么办。他的想法是出去做一些显然从未做过的事情。
Let's go to the neighborhoods where we got crushed and talk to the people who voted against us and ask them why they did that. And when I suggested the idea, Ira, to be totally honest, I didn't know if those voters would talk with us. I'd never done anything like this.
让我们去那些我们惨败的社区，和那些投反对票的人交谈，问问他们为什么这么做。艾拉，老实说，当我提出这个想法时，我不知道那些选民是否会和我们交谈。我从未做过这样的事。
Not only had he never done anything like this, he'd never heard of anybody else doing it, either. And he'd been in politics for over 40 years-- the campaign manager for candidates in New York City, organizing minority voters in Ohio, organizing for the National Gay and Lesbian Task Force.
他不仅从未做过这样的事，甚至没听说过有谁做过。他已经在政治领域工作了40多年——曾担任纽约市候选人的竞选经理，在俄亥俄州组织少数族裔选民，并为全国男女同性恋者特遣部队工作。
I've been doing political work my whole adult life. I've been doing organizing since I was a boy. And conventional wisdom among political practitioners is you don't talk to the people who are against you.
我整个成年生活都在做政治工作。我从小时候就开始做组织工作了。政治从业者中的传统智慧是，你不要和反对你的人谈话。
OK, note what he's saying here. It's not just that you don't try to swing them over to your side. You don't talk to them at all.
好吧，注意他这里说的话。这不仅仅是不试图把他们拉拢到你这一边。而是你根本不和他们谈话。
You spend your time and energy talking first to people who completely agree with you to make sure they vote. And then you go to this tiny, tiny, tiny-- and I mean tiny-- universe of people who you've detected as quote-unquote "undecided," which itself is a very misleading term. And that's it.
你把时间和精力花在先与完全同意你的人谈话，以确保他们去投票。然后，你再去找那些极小、极小、极小——我指的是极小——被你归类为所谓“未决定”的选民群体，这本身就是一个非常具有误导性的词。就这样。
Until he said this to me, it had never occurred to me that all the billions of dollars spent on politics in this country is mostly making messages that say, you already love this or you already fear that. So here's how you should vote. There's not much effort to change anybody's underlying political beliefs, to get your opponents to agree with you.
在他对我这么说之前，我从未想过这个国家在政治上花费的数十亿美元，大多是为了制造那些要么说“你已经热爱这个”，要么说“你已经恐惧那个”的信息。所以这就是你应该如何投票的原因。几乎没有人努力去改变任何人的深层政治信仰，去让你的对手同意你的观点。
So now Dave was going to send dozens of volunteers into Los Angeles neighborhoods that had overwhelmingly voted against them to talk. And because nobody ever does this, field organizer Steve Deline says the first question was--
所以现在戴夫打算派几十名志愿者进入那些绝大多数投票反对他们的洛杉矶社区去进行交谈。因为没人会这样做，现场组织者史蒂夫·德莱恩说，第一个问题是——
First-- I mean, I'll be honest. At first, it was just seeing if we could even have a conversation with someone who didn't agree with us. If they would even talk to us. That was literally the first part of the experiment.
首先——说实话。起初，这只是为了看看我们是否甚至能和一个不同意我们的人进行对话。看看他们是否愿意和我们谈。这确实是实验的最初阶段。
The organizers had assumed that these voters were against gay marriage because they didn't know any gay people. And the first surprise was most of them did. But they'd never sat down and had a real conversation about homosexuality in their lives.
组织者曾假设这些选民反对同性婚姻是因为他们不认识任何同性恋者。但第一个惊喜是，他们中的大多数人其实都认识。只是他们从未坐下来，就同性恋在他们生活中的存在进行过真正的谈话。
And figuring out what to say to these voters to change their minds about gay marriage? It took them a really long time to figure that out. It was not obvious at all how to do it. And they tried lots of stuff that just fizzled. And the missteps are actually kind of interesting, because they point to what does not work and what does work to get any of us to change our minds.
要弄清楚该对这些选民说什么才能改变他们对同性婚姻的看法？他们花了好长一段时间才搞清楚。到底该怎么做根本不明显。他们尝试了很多收效甚微的方法。这些失误其实挺有趣的，因为它们指出了什么方法无效，以及什么方法能真正让任何一个人改变想法。
Like for instance, the first thing that they tried was an appeal to idealism, to principles. Stuff we all agree with.
比如，他们尝试的第一件事是对理想主义、原则的呼吁。那些我们都同意的事情。
Like this is about equality. It's about the golden rule and treating each other the way we want to be treated.
就像这关乎平等。关乎黄金法则，关乎以我们希望被对待的方式去对待他人。
The problem with that, they found, is that it kept the conversation at this very rational, reasonable, intellectual level.
他们发现，这个方法的问题在于它把谈话限制在了非常理性、合理、知性的层面。
And that's not where people make their decisions about issues like this. People make their decisions about how they're going to vote on this at a gut level. And at a visceral level. And at an emotional level.
而人们并不是在那个层面决定这类问题的。人们是在直觉、本能和情感层面上决定如何进行这次投票的。
If anything, talking to people about ideals like equality and what marriage means actually made canvassers miss opportunities to talk about stuff that would be way more effective. Like with this voter, who voted against gay marriage for religious reasons.
如果说有什么影响的话，谈论关于平等和婚姻意义这类理想的话题，实际上让拉票员错过了谈论更有效话题的机会。就像这位选民，出于宗教原因投票反对同性婚姻。
I have two very good male friends that want to get married.
我有两个非常好的男性朋友想结婚。
What are their names?
他们叫什么名字？
[BLEEP] and [BLEEP].
（哔——）和（哔——）。
We're beeping their names to protect their privacy.
我们为了保护他们的隐私对名字进行了消音。
And do [BLEEP] and [BLEEP] know how you feel about this issue?
那么（哔——）和（哔——）知道你对这个问题的看法吗？
No.
不知道。
They don't. How do you think they would feel if they were aware of--
他们不知道。如果你意识到——你觉得他们会怎么想？
[BLEEP] is a very good friend of mine. Extremely good friend of mine. And I think he would be disappointed. But he's never asked me how I felt about it.
（哔——）是我一个非常好的朋友。极其好的朋友。我想他会感到失望。但他从未问过我的感受。
Sure. And so it sounds like you're very fair. You want people to have the same rights.
当然。所以听起来你很公正。你希望人们拥有相同的权利。
A plane's coming in so it's hard to hear. But the canvasser's saying, "It sounds like you want people to have the same rights as other Americans." And right there, Steve says, by doing that, the canvasser has made a mistake. Because she's moving the conversation away from the personal and the emotional, towards these abstract ideas of equality and equal rights.
有飞机经过，所以很难听清。但拉票员说：“听起来你希望人们拥有和其他美国人一样的权利。”就在那里，史蒂夫说，拉票员犯了一个错误。因为她把谈话从个人和情感层面转移到了关于平等和平等权利的抽象观念上。
It's kind of retreating from the thing that is probably on the canvasser's mind, but she's maybe a little nervous to ask, which is why don't you want [BLEEP] to get married if he means this much to you? Basically, we don't know anything about [BLEEP]. We don't know. When did she find out that he was gay? What did she feel like when she first found out that he was gay? Did it scare her? Was it no big deal? Have they been able to talk about it? Does she know his partner? All these things that would help us understand, OK, you know someone who's gay, but you're still worried what might happen if he got married. So what's that all about, you know?
这有点像是从拉票员心里想的事情上撤退了，但她也许有点紧张不敢问，那就是：如果他对你意义如此重大，为什么你不希望（哔——）结婚呢？基本上，我们对（哔——）一无所知。我们不知道。她是什么时候发现他是同性恋的？她第一次发现他是同性恋时是什么感觉？这让她感到害怕吗？还是没什么大不了的？他们能谈论这个吗？她认识他的伴侣吗？所有这些能帮助我们理解的事情——好吧，你认识一个同性恋，但你仍然担心如果他结婚会发生什么。那么，这到底是怎么回事，你知道吗？
This is what they learned-- to stop telling people things. That they should have no road map for the conversation. Instead, the canvassers could talk personally about their own experiences. That seemed to help and connect with voters. But that, by itself, was not enough. The most important thing they could do was, they had to listen. And when the voter gave a clue about something that seemed real and emotional and important to them, find out more. See where it leads.
这就是他们学到的东西——停止向人们灌输道理。他们不应该为对话准备路线图。相反，拉票员可以从个人角度谈论自己的经历。这似乎有助于与选民建立联系。但仅凭这一点是不够的。他们能做的最重要的事情是，他们必须倾听。当选民提供了一些看起来真实、感性且对他们来说很重要的事情时，去深入了解。看看它会引向何处。
And I think the big revelation was that our job was actually to go and give them the chance to talk about their own life. And realize that maybe that led them to conclusions that were a little different than they'd thought.
我认为重大的发现是，我们的工作实际上是去给他们机会谈论他们自己的生活。并意识到，这或许引导他们得出了与之前想象略有不同的结论。
The very first conversation that captured this new approach on video was this voter that they all came to call Mustang Man, because the interview happened in the guy's driveway with this beautiful vintage Mustang that he was very proud of that had been his wife's.
第一个在视频中捕捉到这种新方法的对话是这位被他们统称为“野马男”（Mustang Man）的选民，因为采访是在这家伙的车道上进行的，他对自己那辆美丽的古董野马车非常自豪，那是他妻子的车。
Some people say, "When my wife died, it broke my heart." Well, no. It didn't break my heart. It put a hole in it. And it won't heal. My wife's been gone 11 years now. It feels more like 11 days. I've never gotten over my wife.
有些人说，“我妻子去世时，我的心碎了。”好吧，不。我的心没有碎。而是被掏了一个洞。而且永远不会愈合。我妻子已经离开11年了。感觉就像只过了11天。我从未走出失去妻子的阴影。
The canvasser here is actually Dave Fleischer, the guy whose idea it was to originally go out and talk to voters. And he does not say anything at all to this guy about ideals. He doesn't pitch him any reasons to vote for gay marriage. Instead, he asks about the gay people in this guy's life. And mostly, he  just stands there as the voter just sort of connect the dots in his own life that he had never bothered to connect before.
这里的拉票员实际上是戴夫·弗莱彻，当初提出去和选民交谈的人。他没有对这家伙说任何关于理想的话。他没有向他推销任何投票支持同性婚姻的理由。相反，他问的是这家伙生活中同性恋者的情况。而且大多数时候，他只是站在那里，听这位选民理清他自己生活中从未费心去连接的点。
And then marriage, I can even tell, just the way you talk about her--
还有婚姻，我甚至能感觉到，就从你谈论她的方式来看——
I would want these gay people to be happy, too. I've got a gay couple across the street there. She's a lesbian. And I get along just great with them. In fact, she parks her car in my yard because we got so many cars here, people have no place to park in the street. So I let her park here. And they're wonderful people. They don't bother anybody. You don't see them trying to hit on other women or whatever. They're happy. Just like I was with my wife.
我也希望这些同性恋朋友能幸福。我街对面就住着一对同性恋。她是女同性恋。我和他们相处得非常好。事实上，她把车停在我院子里，因为我们这里车太多，街上没地方停车。所以我让她停在那儿。他们是很棒的人。他们不打扰任何人。你不会看到他们试图去调戏其他女性什么的。他们很幸福。就像我和我妻子在一起时一样。
You know this issue is going to come up for a vote again in the future.
你知道这个问题在未来还会被投票表决。
I would vote for it this time.
我这次会投赞成票。
Vote in favor of allowing gay and lesbian couples to marry? Why does that feel right to you?
投票支持允许同性伴侣结婚？为什么你觉得这样做是对的？
Let's see. [SIGHS] How would I say that? I would hope that they would find the happiness that I had with mine. If you could have that kind of relationship with your partner or the other sex, I would say you're a very lucky person. Because I know I had it. But yeah, that's what I would wish on them. That they'd be as happy as I was with mine. Irrelevant by getting with the other sex.
让我想想。（叹气）我该怎么说呢？我希望他们能找到我和我妻子在一起时拥有的那种幸福。如果你能和你的伴侣或异性拥有那种关系，我会说你是一个非常幸运的人。因为我知道我拥有过。但是的，这就是我希望他们能得到的。我希望他们像我和我妻子一样幸福。这与对方的性别无关。
It did occur to the organizers that as sincere as these conversations seemed, maybe the voters were just being polite at the end. And when they said they would vote for gay marriage, they were just saying what they thought the canvassers wanted to hear-- hadn't really changed their minds. Which is why they invited in two political scientists-- one from UCLA named Michael LaCour, another from Columbia University named Donald Green-- who designed a case controlled study that was eventually published in the journal Science . Green told me that he expected the results would show--
组织者确实想过，尽管这些对话看起来很真诚，但也许选民最后只是为了礼貌。当他们说会投票支持同性婚姻时，他们只是说了他们认为拉票员想听的话——并没有真正改变他们的想法。这就是为什么他们邀请了两位政治学家——一位是加州大学洛杉矶分校的迈克尔·拉库尔（Michael LaCour），另一位是哥伦比亚大学的唐纳德·格林（Donald Green）——他们设计了一项对照案例研究，最终发表在《科学》杂志上。格林告诉我，他预期的结果显示——
Short-term effects. I thought that those effects would subside in a few days' time.
短期的效果。我以为这些效果会在几天内消退。
He thought that because pretty much, that's what always happens. It's rare for people to change your opinions. And it's temporary.
他这样认为，因为基本上，这总是发生的情况。人们改变观点是罕见的。而且是暂时的。
Because very often in public opinion research, which you tend to see in the wake of political events, is a short-term bump followed by a kind of re-equilibration to a pre-existing baseline.
因为在政治事件发生后的公众舆论研究中，你往往会看到一个短期冲击，随后回归到预先存在的基准线上。
In other words, people go back to believing what they used to. And the big surprise was six months, nine months, a year after the canvassers visited, the voters stayed changed. The researchers were so skeptical that this could be real that they did the entire study a second time-- a huge cost, by the way. Hundreds of thousands of dollars. And again, the same result. Professor Green says he and his colleagues have read 900 papers. And they haven't seen anything like this result-- anyone who's changed people's views and it lasted like this.
换句话说，人们回到了他们过去所相信的东西。最大的惊喜是，在拉票员造访六个月、九个月、一年后，选民们的改变仍然持续着。研究人员对这是否真实持怀疑态度，以至于他们又做了一次完整的实验——顺便说一句，成本巨大。数十万美元。结果仍然一样。格林教授说，他和他的同事阅读了900篇论文。他们还没见过这样的结果——有人改变了人们的观点，而且像这样持续下去。
But there's an important details in their findings. The voters who talked to straight canvassers-- they changed their opinions. But it lasted just for a couple weeks. Then they went back to their original opinions. It was only the voters who talked to gay canvassers whose opinions changed and stayed changed a year later. For those voters, the numbers are impressive. Before talking to the canvassers, 47% of these voters supported gay marriage. Immediately after the canvas, it jumped six points higher. And then a year later, it was even higher than that. It was 62%. A total growth of 15%, which Steve Deline points out is--
但他们的研究结果中有一个重要的细节。那些和异性恋拉票员谈话的选民——他们确实改变了观点。但这只持续了几个星期。然后他们又回到了最初的观点。只有那些和同性恋拉票员谈话的选民，他们的观点改变了，并且一年后仍然保持不变。对于这些选民来说，数字令人印象深刻。在与拉票员交谈之前，47%的选民支持同性婚姻。拉票后立即上升了6个百分点。一年后，甚至更高。达到了62%。总共增长了15%，史蒂夫·德莱恩指出这是——
More than enough added support to go from losing an election to winning one.
足以从输掉选举到赢得选举的额外支持。
By the way, the control group-- voters who were not canvassed about gay marriage at all-- they also increased support for gay marriage that year. Because we live in a country where attitudes are changing on this issue everywhere. But the control group only rose by three percentage points, much less than 15%.
顺便说一下，对照组——那些根本没有就同性婚姻被拉票的选民——那一年他们对同性婚姻的支持率也有所增加。因为我们生活在一个到处都在改变对这个问题态度的国家。但对照组仅上升了3个百分点，远低于15%。
It seemed like they'd invented something new, a new tool to use to change people's opinions. But they wondered if it only applied to this one issue. And maybe they picked an easy target, after all-- trying to flip people on an issue that the whole country was changing on anyway.
看起来他们发明了一些新东西，一种用来改变人们观点的新工具。但他们怀疑这是否只适用于这一个议题。毕竟，他们可能挑选了一个容易的目标——试图在一个整个国家都在改变态度的议题上扭转人们的看法。
So they decided to try the new technique with an issue where public opinion has been deadlocked for years. Abortion. These canvassers, no surprise, were pro-choice. And they teamed up with Planned Parenthood to do the canvassing.
所以他们决定在一个公共舆论多年来一直陷于僵局的议题上尝试这种新技术。堕胎。不出所料，这些拉票员都是支持堕胎选择权的。他们与美国计划生育协会合作进行了拉票。
Hi. We're talking to registered voters in your neighborhood today about their views on abortion.
你好。我们今天在您的社区和注册选民谈论他们对堕胎的看法。
A canvasser with a clipboard talks to a California voter through a screen door. The canvasser's young with tattoos and a halter top. The voter's older and heavy-set with wire-rimmed glasses. She's a nurse. And when asked where she is on a scale of zero to 10, where zero means women should have no access to abortion and 10 means they should have full access, she says zero. She's Catholic, from Mexico.
一个拿着剪贴板的拉票员通过纱门和一个加州选民交谈。拉票员很年轻，有纹身，穿着挂脖上衣。选民年纪较大，身体壮实，戴着细框眼镜。她是一名护士。当被问及在0到10的比例中她处于什么位置，0代表女性不应有堕胎途径，10代表她们应有完全的途径时，她说0。她是天主教徒，来自墨西哥。
And then they start this conversation. And here's how the canvasser tries to kick things off in a way that's going to get the voter talking about her real experiences and her real feelings on this very delicate issue.
然后他们开始了这次谈话。以下是拉票员试图以一种能让选民谈论她在这个极其微妙的问题上的真实经历和真实感受的方式开始话题。
So abortion isn't something that a lot of people talk about, which is why we're out here today talking to people about abortion. Have you ever had a conversation with someone about your thoughts on abortion?
所以堕胎并不是很多人谈论的话题，这就是为什么我们今天在这里和大家谈论堕胎。您曾经和别人谈过您对堕胎的想法吗？
My daughters.
我的女儿们。
Your daughters?
您的女儿们？
Yes.
是的。
She says it was when they were teenagers, when each first got her period.
她说那是她们十几岁的时候，每个人第一次来月经时。
How did that feel for you to talk to your daughters?
您和女儿们谈论时感觉如何？
It's not easy. Especially because in my country, they have taboos. A lot of taboos. My mother is one of the person, never talking about sexual relations or conceptions. That's why I try to be very open with my daughters.
不容易。特别是因为在我的国家，有禁忌。很多禁忌。我母亲就是那样的人，从不谈论性关系或受孕。这就是为什么我努力对我的女儿们保持非常开放的态度。
My mother's from the Philippines. And my mother went through the same feeling. It's not something that you talk about.
我母亲来自菲律宾。我母亲也经历了同样的感觉。这不是你会谈论的事情。
No. It's not. And my family is the same.
不。不是的。我的家庭也一样。
My mother never talked to me about abortion. In fact, it was a really scary thing to talk about. When I got my period, I was 12 years old.
我母亲从未和我谈过堕胎。事实上，谈论这个是非常可怕的事情。我12岁来月经时。
What follows is just an intensely real conversation about their lives. The voter says that when she was six, her mother miscarried a baby. But nobody explained what was going on to her. When she was 11 and got her period, nobody explained what was happening and how scary that was. And so she tried to be different with her daughters. That's why she became a nurse, to help women. Now and then the canvasser points out things and underlines things in the voter's life story, nudging her to kind of connect the dots. Like when the voter talks about her daughters, the canvasser says--
接下来的谈话是对他们生活极其真实的描述。这位选民说，她六岁时，母亲流产了一个孩子。但没人向她解释发生了什么。她11岁来月经时，没人解释发生了什么，那有多可怕。所以她努力在对待女儿们时有所不同。这就是她成为护士的原因，为了帮助女性。偶尔，拉票员会指出并强调选民生活故事中的点滴，引导她去连接这些点。就像当选民谈论她的女儿们时，拉票员说——
It sounds like you are very supportive of their choices, even if you may not agree with them.
听起来您非常支持她们的选择，即使您可能不同意。
I try to do.
我尽量。
But mostly they just swap stories. And 15 minutes into this 22-minute conversation, the canvasser reveals this.
但大多数时候，他们只是交换故事。在这22分钟谈话的第15分钟，拉票员透露了这一点。
I had an abortion in November this past year.
我在去年11月做过一次堕胎。
I'm so sorry.
我很抱歉。
It wasn't the wrong choice for me, because that's what felt right for me. But I was alone. And it was scary. It was because I don't know how to talk about it with people. Like my family, my mother loves me. And so does my papa and my sister.
那对我来说不是错误的选择，因为那是我觉得正确的做法。但我很孤独。而且很可怕。那是因为我不知道如何和别人谈论它。比如我的家人，我母亲爱我。我的爸爸和姐妹也爱我。
I know. But it's hard. And you carry it for the rest of your life. It's your decision. But you carry it for the rest of your life.
我知道。但这很难。而且你要带着它过完余生。这是你的决定。但你要带着它过完余生。
One of the things that I struggled with in telling my family is this idea that my family is going to love me less.
我在告诉家人时挣扎的事情之一是这种想法：我的家人会减少对我的爱。
No. Never.
不。绝不会。
Would you ever love your daughters less?
您会减少对您女儿们的爱吗？
No. Never.
不。绝不会。
It's a moment that's simultaneously intimate and manipulative and honest. All at once. And it works. After this, the canvasser asked the voter again to rate on a scale of zero to 10 where she stands on access to abortion. Remember, she was a zero before.
这是一个既亲密又带有操纵性，同时也真实诚恳的瞬间。三者兼具。而且奏效了。之后，拉票员再次要求选民给她在堕胎途径上的立场打分，按0到10的比例。记住，她之前是0。
We have that same zero to 10 scale where zero means no access and 10 means full access.
我们有同样的0到10比例，0代表无途径，10代表完全途径。
10.
10。
A 10?
10分？
Mm-hm.
嗯。
Researcher Michael LaCour is running a study about the abortion canvassing. This one hasn't been published yet. He's only been tracking the voters for 200 days so far. But preliminary data indicates that the canvassers did change people's minds. The number of voters who favored abortion to be legal in all cases grows five percentage points after talking to the canvassers. And the 5% stayed that way. They haven't changed back 200 days later. But-- and this is the important but-- that change only happens when the canvassers are women who've had abortions who reveal that fact to voters. Other canvassers don't get the long-term change. So in a sense, it's very similar to what happens with gay canvassers talking about gay marriage. When the people most affected by an issue show up at your door and talk to you, that's the thing that can change your mind.
研究员迈克尔·拉库尔正在进行一项关于堕胎拉票的研究。这个还没有发表。他目前只追踪了这些选民200天。但初步数据表明，拉票员确实改变了人们的想法。在和拉票员交谈后，赞成堕胎在任何情况下都应合法的选民比例增加了5个百分点。而且这5%保持不变。200天后，他们没有改回来。但是——这是重要的转折——这种改变只有在拉票员是曾经堕胎并向选民透露这一事实的女性时才会发生。其他拉票员无法获得长期的改变。所以在某种意义上，这和同性恋拉票员谈论同性婚姻时发生的情况非常相似。当受某个议题影响最大的人出现在你门口并和你交谈时，那是能改变你想法的东西。
Of course, it was liberals doing this canvassing. So they pushed a liberal agenda. But researcher Donald Green says conservatives could probably use this technique just as productively.
当然，是自由派在做这项拉票工作。所以他们推动了自由派的议程。但研究员唐纳德·格林说，保守派可能也可以同样富有成效地使用这种技术。
Probably so. I think it's a matter of, again, changing the face that people associate with a given issue. So you can imagine, for example, a conservative group doing this on something like school choice.
很可能可以。我想这又是一个改变人们与特定议题相关联的面孔的问题。所以你可以想象，例如，一个保守派团体在学校选择权之类的议题上做这件事。
So in other words, parents, or maybe even high school kids who had been in a certain kind of school would go out and go door to door and just talk in a heartfelt way about their experiences in school.
所以换句话说，父母，或者甚至是曾经就读于某种学校的高中生，会走门串户，只是发自肺腑地谈论他们在学校的经历。
That's right.
没错。
Do you think it could work for abortion for the other side? Women who regretted having an abortion would go door to door and just talk about that in a real way.
你认为这能在堕胎问题上对另一方有效吗？后悔堕胎的女性会走门串户，只是真实地谈论那件事。
It could be. I think what's kind of interesting about this is that when I talk to professionals about this technique, this does not inspire a lot of interest on their part. Because of course, it can't be done on a large scale at low cost. And they don't want to invest the kinds of resources and training and supervision necessary to generate an army of canvassers that can actually change minds.
有可能。我认为关于这一点有趣的是，当我与专业人士谈论这种技术时，他们对此并没有产生多大兴趣。因为当然，它无法以低成本大规模地进行。他们不想投入必要的资源、培训和监督来产生一支能够真正改变人们想法的拉票大军。
It is expensive. The Los Angeles LGBT Center spent nearly $2.5 million over four years and reached just 12,000 voters. That is not many voters when you consider they last Prop 8 by 600,000 votes. In a state like California with 17 million voters, they'd have to spend a real fortune to have an impact on any election. Cheaper, by far, to make a scare ad and run it on local TV around the state-- you know, the way politics usually works.
这很昂贵。洛杉矶LGBT中心在四年内花费了近250万美元，只接触了12,000名选民。当你考虑到他们以60万票的差距输掉了第8号提案时，这并没有多少选民。在像加州这样有1700万选民的州，他们需要花一大笔钱才能对任何选举产生影响。相比之下，制作一个恐怖广告并在全州的当地电视上播放要便宜得多——你知道，这是政治通常运作的方式。
Coming up, getting criminals to change by giving them exactly what they want-- or one of the things they want, anyway. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio when our program continues.
接下来，通过给罪犯他们真正想要的东西——或者至少是他们想要的东西之一——来改变他们。这一节将在芝加哥公共广播节目的下一部分播出。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today on our program, the incredible rarity of anyone changing their minds. We have stories today about why it happens in the rare instances that it does happen. We've arrived at Act Two of our program. Act Two, Crime Pays.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。在今天的节目中，我们谈论改变想法的罕见性。我们今天的故事讲述了这种改变在极少数情况下发生的原因。我们已经进入了节目的第二幕。第二幕，犯罪也是有回报的（Crime Pays）。
So Richmond, California is right across the bay from San Francisco. And it has been a pretty violent place. Quick illustration of that. The city's police chief, Chris Magnus-- at a press conference, he holds up a cellphone to play a recording made at 11:00 at night there.
里士满（Richmond），加利福尼亚，就在旧金山湾对面。它一直是一个相当暴力的地方。对此做一个简单的说明。该市警察局长克里斯·马格努斯（Chris Magnus）在新闻发布会上举起手机，播放了一段晚上11点在那里录制的录音。
[GUNSHOTS]
（枪声）
He starts to put the cell phone down, then realizes it's not over.
他开始放下手机，然后意识到还没有结束。
[GUNSHOTS]
（枪声）
Back in 2006, Richmond was named the ninth most dangerous city in the country, with 42 murders for a population of about 100,000. Then they brought in a new police chief and started doing all kinds of things differently. And it worked. Homicides are now a third of what they were. Crime has dropped in a way that is dramatic and impressive. And police say that one of the things that helped is a program called the Office of Neighborhood Safety, or ONS. Bland name for what is actually a very unusual program with one particular tactic that you do not hear about people trying very often. Joe Richman explains.
回到2006年，里士满被列为全国第九大危险城市，在约10万人口中发生了42起谋杀案。然后他们请来了一位新的警察局长，并开始以各种方式改变做法。这奏效了。凶杀案现在只有过去的三分之一。犯罪率的下降既剧烈又令人印象深刻。警方表示，有所帮助的其中一件事是一个名为“社区安全办公室”（Office of Neighborhood Safety，简称ONS）的项目。这个名字对于一个实际上非常不寻常、且有一种你很少听说人们经常尝试的特殊策略的项目来说显得平淡无奇。乔·里奇曼（Joe Richman）解释说。
The big aha moment for the head of ONS, DeVone Boggan, came when he was in a meeting with police officers. They told him a number-- that Richmond police believed that 70% of the shootings in the city involved just 17 guys.
ONS负责人德冯·博根（DeVone Boggan）的关键顿悟时刻发生在一次与警官的会议上。他们告诉他一个数字——里士满警方认为该市70%的枪击事件涉及仅仅17个人。
17 people. And I'll tell you, I almost flipped out of my chair. Cause I was like, 17 people? That's nothing.
17个人。我告诉你，我差点从椅子上翻过去。因为我想，17个人？那算什么。
Boggan realized that if they could reach just those 17 guys and get them to change, they could really make a dent in the problem. He asked the police for a list of those 17 names. He did his own research and added more names. To get on that list, Boggan said, you basically had to have shot someone.
博根意识到，如果他们能接触到那17个人并让他们改变，他们就能真正解决这个问题。他向警方索要了那17个人的名单。他自己做了研究并添加了更多名字。博根说，要进入那份名单，你基本上必须射杀过人。
Next, he put together a team of street outreach workers. All of them were from Richmond. Most had served time in prison themselves. And he sent them out to get to know the guys on the list and deliver this message-- come to a meeting and we will provide you with a lifestyle alternative that could change your life for the good. Boggan had no idea if any of them would come.
接下来，他组建了一支街头外展工作队。他们全都是里士满本地人。大多数人自己也曾入狱服刑。他派他们出去结识名单上的人，并传达这个信息——来参加一个会议，我们将为您提供一种可以让你人生变得美好的生活方式替代选择。博根不知道他们中是否会有人来。
The meeting was scheduled three months later. By that time, a couple of guys on the list were dead. One was in jail. Four others weren't interested. But the rest of the guys agreed. 21 guys.
会议定在三个月后举行。到那时，名单上的几个人已经死了。一个在监狱里。另外四个不感兴趣。但剩下的人同意了。21个人。
Boggan has a sense of theater. And rather than hold the meeting in one of the neighborhood community centers, he had the men come to City Hall. The meeting took place in a fancy conference room with views of San Francisco across the bay.
博根有一种戏剧感。他没有在其中一个社区中心举行会议，而是让这些人来到市政厅。会议在市政厅一间可以俯瞰海湾对面旧金山的豪华会议室里举行。
It's a square table. Great wood. It's a good room. They come in and they have name placards-- their full names, not their street names. Information packets. Things to sign. We wanted them to walk into the room and go, what the heck is this?
那是一张方形桌子。上好的木材。那是个好房间。他们走进来，有姓名牌——他们的全名，不是绰号。信息包。要签名的文件。我们希望他们走进房间时会想，这到底是什么鬼？
But it was what Boggan did at the end of that meeting that really got everyone's attention, both inside and outside of that room.
但博根在会议结束时所做的事情才真正引起了每个人的注意，无论是在那个房间里还是外面。
I go into my pocket. And I pull out envelopes. And I handed each of the young men envelopes. And I told them to open the envelope. And they did. And they each had $1,000 check. And they didn't believe that it was real.
我把手伸进口袋。拿出信封。我把信封交给了每个年轻人。我告诉他们打开信封。他们照做了。他们每个人都拿到了一张1,000美元的支票。他们不相信那是真的。
$21,000 in $1,000 checks were given out that day. The message was that changing their lives should be treated like a job. But the money was also a type of marketing strategy, because Boggan wanted the news to spread through the neighborhoods of Richmond. And it did.
那天总共发放了21,000美元，每张支票1,000美元。传达的信息是，改变他们的生活应该被当作一份工作来对待。但这些钱也是一种营销策略，因为博根希望这个新闻能在里士满的社区传播开来。事实也的确如此。
That first meeting was five years ago. And since then, they've done it every 18 months with a new group.
第一次会议是五年前举行的。从那以后，他们每18个月用一批新人做一次。
Everybody do me a favor. If you have not signed the sign-in, sign the sign-in after you've signed your paperwork. Date your paperwork.
每个人帮我一个忙。如果您还没有签到，请在签署文书后补签。在您的文书上写上日期。
All of the guys in the meeting are African American. They're spread out evenly around the conference table, behind name plates with Mr. in front of their names. But these guys look really young. Some of them are just 15 or 16. They definitely don't look like a city's worst criminals. It's different from the meeting five years ago, because they've had so much success with the older guys. Now, they say, they're fishing upstream. Taking younger guys who have gotten in less trouble. This is the youngest group they've ever had.
参加会议的人全是黑人。他们均匀地散布在会议桌旁，名字前带有“先生”字样的名牌后面。但这些人看起来真的很年轻。有些人甚至只有15或16岁。他们看起来绝对不像一个城市里最坏的罪犯。这与五年前的会议不同，因为他们在年长者身上取得了巨大成功。现在，他们说，他们正在“向上游捕鱼”。带走那些惹麻烦较少的小家伙。这是他们有史以来最年轻的一组人。
Today's meeting is led by Sam Vaughn, one of the program's outreach workers. Everyone who shows up knows what's coming, that they're going to get paid. Sam Vaughn tells them straight up.
今天的会议由项目的外展工作者之一萨姆·沃恩（Sam Vaughn）领导。所有到场的人都知道接下来会发生什么，他们会拿到钱。萨姆·沃恩直言不讳地告诉他们。
The problem is, folk don't believe. They don't feel like you deserve it. Folk don't feel like-- that's a waste of money. Might as well save that money for the jail cell.
问题是，人们不相信。他们觉得你不值得。人们不觉得——那是在浪费钱。不如把那笔钱留给监狱牢房。
We don't believe that that's the case. We're doing this because this community and this city cannot be safe without partnering with you. And you deserve it.
我们不相信是这样。我们这样做是因为如果不能与你们合作，这个社区和这座城市就不可能安全。而且你们值得。
So what would these guys actually do to deserve their money? They'll put together a life map with specific benchmarks. And they'll get checks as rewards-- for getting a GED, a driver's license, parenting and finance classes, job training, a job. For now, the first step is to agree, in writing, to an 18-month process of change. And no gunfire.
那么这些人实际上会做什么来获得他们的报酬呢？他们将制定一份生活蓝图，包含具体的基准目标。他们将获得支票作为奖励——为了获得同等学历证书（GED）、驾照、参加育儿和理财课程、职业培训、找到工作。现在，第一步是书面同意一个为期18个月的改变过程。并且不能有枪击事件。
So if y'all  don't got a problem with that, y'all can sign the first sheet.
所以如果你们对此没问题，你们可以签第一张纸。
[INAUDIBLE] law school.
（听不清）法律学校。
So you can sign this again. So you sign both of them.
所以你可以再签一次。所以你们两张都要签。
As the guys sign their contracts, Sam Vaughn passes out their first reward. It's not $1,000 checks anymore. Just $100 Visa gift card. But they find it works just as well.
当这些人签署合同时，萨姆·沃恩发放了他们的第一笔奖励。不再是1,000美元的支票了。只是100美元的Visa礼品卡。但他们发现效果一样好。
That is $100 Visa gift card. All right? Pay your phone bill. Buy some kicks. Whatever it is you're trying to do.
那是100美元的Visa礼品卡。好吗？付你们的电话费。买些球鞋。不管你们想做什么。
Thank you.
谢谢。
You're more than welcome. Thank you. Thank you for making us a priority today. We appreciate you.
不用客气。谢谢你们今天把我们放在首位。我们感激你们。
[DOOR SLAMMING]
（砰的一声关门声）
A few days later, Sam Vaughn is driving around the neighborhoods of Richmond, which is how he spends most of his work day.
几天后，萨姆·沃恩正在里士满的社区周边开车，这就是他大部分工作时间所做的事情。
Across the railroad tracks into north Richmond. And we'll ride around. We'll see folks we know. We'll hop out. And we'll talk with them. Sometimes we're looking for folks. I'm sorry, hold on.
穿过北里士满的铁轨。我们会四处转转。我们会看到认识的人。我们会下车。然后和他们谈谈。有时我们是在寻找某人。抱歉，等一下。
(ON THE PHONE) Bro. I'm all right.
（打手机）兄弟。我没事。
Sam Vaughn is an agent of change in the city of Richmond. That's his actual job title. Neighborhood change agent. And this is what changing someone's life often looks like. Tiny fixes. Being there to remove obstacles, however small, to keep the person on track.
萨姆·沃恩是里士满市的改变推动者。这是他实际的职位名称。社区改变推动者。这就是改变某人生活通常的样子。小小的修补。在场以消除障碍，无论多么微小，让那个人保持在轨道上。
(ON THE PHONE) You just go up there and let them know you're trying to start a payment plan on a citation that you've got. You've got to give them 10% down and then you can pay monthly. So if you ain't got the whole $400--
（打手机）你只需去那里，让他们知道你试图为你收到的罚单制定一个分期付款计划。你必须先付10%的定金，然后就可以每月支付。所以如果你凑不出全部的400美元——
Sam's on the phone with a guy named Cardell who just joined the program. Cardell was stopped in Sacramento a while back and given a ticket for driving without a license. He never paid the fine. And today is his court date. Sam convinced Cardell to deal with it. So Cardell drove without a license to the courthouse in Sacramento to start paying his ticket for driving without a license.
萨姆正在和刚加入该项目的一个叫卡德尔（Cardell）的家伙通电话。卡德尔前段时间在萨克拉门托被拦下，收到了一张无证驾驶的罚单。他从未支付过罚款。今天是他的出庭日。萨姆说服了卡德尔去处理这件事。所以卡德尔在没有驾照的情况下开车去了萨克拉门托的法院，开始为他的无证驾驶罚单付款。
(ON THE PHONE) You have to make the minimum payment. All right, bro. All right.
（打手机）你必须支付最低额度。好的，兄弟。好的。
Sorry. That happens a lot. Because most young people out here, they never get their license because they've gotten tickets before they've gotten their license. And then they never pay their tickets, because the cost of those tickets are insane, especially after you failed to go to court. So now the seat belt ticket that was $92, now you owe $2,200 a year later, because you haven't done anything. And you don't live at the address that they sent the ticket to. It's just chaos.
抱歉。这种情况经常发生。因为这里的大多数年轻人，他们永远拿不到驾照，因为他们在拿到驾照前就收到了罚单。然后他们从不付罚单，因为这些罚单的费用太疯狂了，特别是在你没出庭之后。所以现在原本92美元的安全带罚单，一年后你欠了2,200美元，因为你什么都没做。而且你也不住在他们寄送罚单的地址了。这简直是一团糟。
And now I'm ready to go to work. But I don't have a license. I've gotten to a place in my life where I want to do right. But there's so much holding me back. You kind of give up. So you just stuck in this life, trying to find any kind of way to make a buck. And it definitely deflates them. It gets them to a place where, why  am I trying?
现在我准备好去工作了。但我没有驾照。我的人生已经到了一个我想做好事的地步。但有太多东西在阻碍我。你会有点放弃。所以你被困在这种生活中，试图找到任何赚几块钱的方法。这确实让他们感到泄气。这让他们走到那一步，心想：我为什么要努力？
And I'm sorry, this young man is at the desk calling me.
抱歉，这个年轻人在桌子那边给我打电话。
(ON THE PHONE) Hey, bro.
（打手机）嘿，兄弟。
Cardell calls back.
卡德尔回电了。
(ON THE PHONE) Hold on. Hold on one second.
（打手机）等等。等一下。
He doesn't have his state ID number.
他没有州身份证号。
I'm so glad I brought this bag.
真高兴我带了这个包。
But Sam does. Sam pulls the car over at a 7-Eleven, digs out a manila folder, and reads the number into the phone.
但萨姆有。萨姆把车停在一家7-11便利店，翻出一个马尼拉文件夹，把号码读进了电话里。
(ON THE PHONE) Hello? It's F as in Frank.
（打手机）喂？是F代表Frank的F。
Driving around with Sam, it feels as close to being with change expert as I can imagine. He's thought a lot about how people change. So I kept peppering him with questions with the word change in them. 24 questions. I listened back later and counted. I was looking for some theory about what it takes for people to transform themselves. And he tried to play along.
和萨姆一起开车，感觉就像我能想象到的最接近与“改变专家”在一起的状态。他思考过很多关于人们如何改变的问题。所以我不断地用带有“改变”这个词的问题轰炸他。24个问题。我后来回听时数了一下。我一直在寻找关于人们改造自我所需的某种理论。他试图配合我。
So yes, I know you're trying to get that little plug and that little one-liner. I just don't know how you're going to make it work. [LAUGHS] I just don't. But changing your mind is the easiest part in the world. Saying, "This is something that I want to do. I believe that I can do this. I believe I can be a different man. I believe I can be successful. I believe I can be a good father. I believe I can stop using drugs. I believe I can get a job." And believing all these things is fantastic. But if I don't have the tools and the mechanisms to do something different, I revert back to my old ways.
所以是的，我知道你想得到那个小插头和那句俏皮话。我只是不知道你打算怎么让它奏效。（笑）我真的不知道。但改变想法是世界上最容易的部分。说：“这是我想做的事情。我相信我能做到。我相信我能成为一个不同的人。我相信我能成功。我相信我能成为一个好父亲。我相信我能停止吸毒。我相信我能找到工作。”相信所有这些事情都很棒。但如果我没有工具和机制去采取不同的行动，我肯定会回到老路上去。
Like if I want to be a vegetarian, but then there ain't no vegetarian food, I'm just eating apples. That's the  only thing they got. I'm back on meat in a week for sure. That's just what it is.
就像如果我想成为素食主义者，但却没有素食，我就只能吃苹果。那是他们唯一有的东西。那我保证一周之内肯定又吃回肉了。事实就是这样。
Giving people these tools takes time. Sam and the other change agents check in with the guys in the program pretty much every day. Sam is here to meet with a guy who signed up four days ago.
给人们这些工具需要时间。萨姆和其他改变推动者几乎每天都会查看项目中的学员情况。萨姆在这里是要见一个四天前加入的家伙。
You ain't got no gun?
你没带枪吧？
It's in the house.
在房子里。
Why it ain't on your waist?
为什么不在你腰上？
This is Deandre.
这是迪安德（Deandre）。
First of all, I, don't really like you. No, I'm joking, dog. [LAUGHS]
首先，我，其实不太喜欢你。不，我开玩笑的，伙计。（笑）
He's 20 years old, although he looks 16. They're standing next to Sam's car parked in Deandre's mother's driveway.
他今年20岁，虽然看起来只有16岁。他们站在萨姆车旁，车停在迪安德母亲的车道上。
Real talk. I'm glad you decided to do this. For me, what it's showing is that you're trying to do something different with your life. And you possibly think that's that baby coming. So I'd ask you, why don't you tell me how that happened, though, bro? And not the specifics, because I know how it happens. But how did you let that happen? How would you get to a place where you feel like you're ready to be responsible for another life, when you can't even figure out your own right now?
说真的。很高兴你决定这样做。对我来说，这表明你正在尝试用你的生活做一些不同的事情。而你可能觉得那是即将出生的宝宝带来的影响。所以我问你，兄弟，你为什么不告诉我那是怎么发生的？不需要细节，因为我知道它是怎么发生的。你是怎么让那种事发生的？你是怎么走到这一步，让你觉得自己准备好为另一个生命负责，而你自己现在却连自己的生活都还没搞清楚？
I think that's probably what it took for me to realize what I got to do, to maybe better myself so I can make a better situation for my child.
我想那可能就是我意识到我必须要做什么，为了也许能完善自己，好让我能为我的孩子创造一个更好的情况。
I mean, congratulations, but damn at the same time.
我是说，恭喜你，但同时也很糟糕。
All through this conversation, Sam doesn't miss a chance to nudge, to clarify, to keep things realistic.
在整个谈话过程中，萨姆没有放过任何一个推动、澄清、保持现实的机会。
When's she due?
预产期是什么时候？
June 3.
6月3日。
You've got four months. What are you trying to accomplish in four months before your baby get here?
你有四个月时间。在你宝宝到来之前，你这四个月想完成什么？
A lot. I need a job.
很多。我需要一份工作。
Let's be realistic. I want you to say that list, but then we're going to have to be realistic about it, too. So four months. What are you trying to accomplish?
让我们现实一点。我希望你说出那个清单，但之后我们也得对它现实一点。所以四个月。你到底想完成什么？
I want to accomplish my GED, a job, and be wealthy.
我想完成我的GED（同等学历证书）、一份工作，并且变得富有。
Who?
谁？
Wealthy.
富有。
You're trying to be wealthy in four months? Like, emotionally wealthy? Or financially wealthy?
你四个月内想变得富有？你是说，精神上的富有？还是经济上的富有？
Financially, emotionally.
经济上、精神上。
What's your definition of wealthy? What amount of money is that?
你对富有的定义是什么？是多少钱？
Couple thousand.
几千块。
A couple thousand? Oh, you can have that saved for sure. But if you think, four months, you're just going to have a hundred stacks in the bank, that's just unrealistic. I'm glad you said GED before job. Because that's being realistic. License.
几千块？哦，你可以保证攒下那个数。但如果你想，四个月内，你就想在银行里有十万，那是不现实的。我很高兴你把GED排在工作之前。因为那才叫现实。驾照。
[INAUDIBLE]
（听不清）
All right. Well then, that's what we on then.
好的。那我们就按这个来。
All right. See you later.
好的。待会儿见。
For sure, dog.
肯定的，伙计。
Back in the car, Sam gives a recap.
回到车里，萨姆做了个总结。
I believe he can do it. I do. I believe he has everything it takes to do it. But then he also has to get lucky. Let's not live in a fairy tale land. He's about to have a child in four months. So what happens when that baby needs diapers and food? He's going to provide for his child the best he knows how. And that could possibly lead him to jail or prison. So he's going to have to get lucky. He's going to have to be able to do some things that he probably shouldn't do and get away with them until he gets to a place to where he ain't gotta do them no more.
我相信他能做到。真的。我相信他具备做到所需的一切。但他也必须走运。别生活在童话世界里。他四个月后就要有孩子了。那么当那个婴儿需要尿布和食物时会发生什么？他会尽他所知地供养他的孩子。而这可能会导致他入狱或坐牢。所以他必须走运。他必须能够做一些他可能不该做的事情，并能逃脱惩罚，直到他走到一个他不需要再做这些事的境地。
That's just being realistic.
这才是现实。
That's the reality of it.
这是现实。
This surprised me, the pragmatism of it. They don't expect the guys to change all at once. They know it's going to take a while before they stop committing crimes. And they don't give up on them when they screw up. I met a graduate of the program named D'vondre Woodard. He's 25 now, has a great paying job. He's a big success in the program. And he told me this story.
这让我感到惊讶，这种务实态度。他们不指望这些家伙一下子就改掉。他们知道在他们停止犯罪之前需要一段时间。而且当他们搞砸时，他们也不会放弃他们。我见过一个项目毕业生，名叫德冯德雷·伍达德（D'vondre Woodard）。他现在25岁，有一份收入丰厚的工作。他是该项目的一个巨大成功案例。他告诉了我这个故事。
Four years ago, he was doing well enough in the fellowship that he was given a special reward. ONS has found that even more attractive than the financial stipend is the chance to travel. He'd been to Mexico, South Africa. And in 2011, D'vondre was invited to represent the program in Washington, DC, at President Obama's State of the Union address.
四年前，他在奖学金项目中表现得足够好，获得了一项特殊奖励。ONS发现，比起经济补贴，更具吸引力的是旅行的机会。他去过墨西哥、南非。2011年，德冯德雷受邀代表该项目前往华盛顿特区，参加奥巴马总统的国情咨文演讲。
I just remember Obama speaking.
我还记得奥巴马在演讲。
You're a part of the American family.
你是美国家庭的一员。
And I just remember as he spoke, he always paused. He never "um," you know. Professional with it.
我记得他说话时总是会有停顿。他从不“呃”，你知道的。很专业。
There was D'vondre in the audience, in a suit and tie, on national television, a representative for the ONS program. The thing was, at this point, D'vondre was still selling drugs. He had made changes, for sure. And D'vondre says they were important changes.
德冯德雷就在观众席上，穿着西装系着领带，出现在国家电视台上，作为ONS项目的代表。事实是，此时此刻，德冯德雷还在贩毒。他确实做出了改变。德冯德雷说这些改变很重要。
It wasn't the same drugs, like cocaine, riding around with guns, looking for people. No. My life was totally changed. I'm not doing that no more. What I'm doing is marijuana. A bag here. Bag here. Get pulled over with that, they're not going to take you to jail for that. They're looking for guns and cocaine. That's all the police is looking for.
那不是一样的毒品，像可卡因，带着枪到处跑，找人麻烦。不。我的生活完全改变了。我再也不做那些了。我做的是大麻。这里一袋。那里一袋。带着那个被拦下，他们不会因此把你关进监狱。他们是在找枪和可卡因。警察找的就是这些。
Before he'd make the jump and stop selling drugs completely, D'vondre first wanted a job, a well-paying one. The guys in the program can make as much as $300 to $1000 a month, depending on how well they're meeting their goals. Real money, but not enough to replace with some of them could make selling drugs.
在彻底跳槽停止贩毒之前，德冯德雷首先想要一份报酬丰厚的工作。项目中的学员每个月可以赚到300到1000美元，取决于他们目标达成的情况。虽然是真金白银，但不足以替代他们中有些人贩毒能赚到的钱。
D'vondre figured out a job he wanted, doing maintenance in an oil refinery, like the Chevron plant nearby. He did a six-month training course, only to find out afterwards that he would need a special credential from Homeland Security for this sort of work. And D'vondre didn't qualify because he was a felon.
德冯德雷找到了他想要的工作，在炼油厂做维护，比如附近的雪佛龙（Chevron）工厂。他参加了一个为期六个月的培训课程，事后才发现他需要国土安全部的特殊证书才能做这种工作。德冯德雷因为是重罪犯而不符合资格。
So with help from ONS, he appealed. He got letters of recommendation. He wrote an essay about his past and how he had changed. And he waited for a decision.
因此，在ONS的帮助下，他提出了上诉。他拿到了推荐信。他写了一篇关于他的过去以及他如何改变的文章。然后他等待决定。
About two years.
大约两年。
It took you two years?
你花了两年时间？
It took me two years.
我花了两年时间。
To get those credentials.
拿到那些证书。
It was a waiting game. It was about being patient.
这是一场等待游戏。这关乎耐心。
And you liked the idea of that job more than selling drugs?
你喜欢那份工作的想法胜过贩毒吗？
Yeah. Because it's a job. It's a job. A W-2 form. Taxes, W-2's. How the system works, society's system, the United States' system.
是的。因为它是一份工作。这是一份工作。W-2表格。税收，W-2。系统是如何运作的，社会的系统，美国的系统。
D'vondre got his credentials and learned he would start his new job in a month. And it was at that point-- 30 days away from a brand new job-- that's when D'vondre decided to go cold turkey on illegal activity. No more drug dealing. He said it was like giving himself a test. And he passed.
德冯德雷拿到了他的证书，并得知他一个月后就能开始新工作了。就在那个时刻——距离一份全新工作还有30天——德冯德雷决定冷处理非法活动。不再进行毒品交易。他说这就像是给自己做了一个测试。而且他通过了。
I let it go. I stopped doing what I was doing. I didn't have to no more. I just put it down. Got rid of it. I don't need it no more.
我放手了。我停止了我在做的事情。我不再需要那样做了。我只是放下它。摆脱它。我不再需要它了。
Over the past five years, 68 guys have gone through the ONS fellowship program. How did they do? Four are dead. A few others are in prison. But of the 68, 43 have completed their goals and graduated. But even more important than those numbers, the overwhelming majority of the guys who have gone through the program-- whether they graduated or not-- have had no new arrests or charges for gun-related activities. And by majority, I mean 80%, according to a report that's about to be released by the National Council on Crime and Delinquency that studied the ONS program. Criminologists I talked to said anything over 50% would be considered exceptional. You'd expect most of them to fail.
在过去五年里，68名学员通过了ONS研究员项目。他们表现如何？四人死亡。另一些人在监狱里。但在68人中，43人完成了目标并毕业了。但比这些数字更重要的是，绝大多数通过该项目的学员——无论是否毕业——在枪支相关活动上没有新的逮捕或指控。根据全国犯罪与少年司法委员会即将发布的一份关于ONS项目的报告，所谓的“绝大多数”指的是80%。我交谈过的犯罪学家说，任何超过50%的比例都会被认为是例外的。你本会预期他们中的大多数会失败。
But the numbers that have received the most attention are the ones with dollar signs in front of them. There have been headlines like "paying people not to kill" or just "crime pays." And internet comments like, "So all I have to do is threaten to kill someone and I get free money from the government? How do I sign up for this gravy train?"
但获得最多关注的数字是前面带有美元符号的那些。标题如“付钱让人不杀人”或者仅仅是“犯罪有回报”。互联网评论如：“所以我要做的就是威胁杀某人，然后我就能从政府那里得到免费的钱？我怎么报名参加这个免费午餐？”
In Richmond, there are plenty of straight-A students or valedictorians from poor families who aren't selling drugs, aren't committing crimes, aren't picking up guns. And they're not getting a stipend from the city for reaching their goals. And Sam Vaughn, who's been with the program, working with these guys for years, he understands the criticism.
在里士满，有很多来自贫困家庭的优等生或告别演说者，他们不贩毒，不犯罪，不拿枪。而他们并没有因为达到目标而从城市那里得到津贴。萨姆·沃恩，他多年来一直在这个项目工作，与这些人打交道，他理解这种批评。
I get it. I get it. I understand it 100%. I was in prison. Society didn't think I deserved anything. I got a college education in prison. Folks had an issue with that. "I work my ass off and I can't afford to pay for my kids' college, this dude breaks the law and goes in here and gets a free education." I understand. I understand that balance. But once again-- and if you want to call it pragmatism, yeah, that's what it is-- I'm coming home. Who do you want to live next door to you? The dude who got the college education and who was able to get in those classes and was able to get a domestic violence certificate or substance abuse certificate? Folk who are really in there working on themselves? Or the dude who's sitting out on the yard playing dominoes all day and working out? Who do you want coming next door to you?
我懂。我懂。我100%理解。我曾入狱服刑。社会不认为我值得任何东西。我在监狱里接受了大学教育。人们对此有意见。“我辛苦工作，却付不起孩子们的大学学费，这家伙违反法律进去，却在这里得到了免费教育。”我理解。我理解那种平衡。但再说一次——如果你想称之为务实，是的，确实如此——我即将回家。你希望住在谁隔壁？那个受过大学教育，能够进入那些课堂，并获得家庭暴力结业证书或药物滥用结业证书的家伙？那些真正致力于改变自我的人？还是那个整天在院子里打多米诺骨牌、健身的家伙？你希望谁住进你隔壁？
There's no other city in America right now that's doing what Richmond is doing-- giving criminals money to turn their lives around. In most places, it would be a tough sell. But the city was desperate. And sometimes that's what it takes for things to change.
美国现在没有其他城市像里士满这样——给罪犯钱来彻底改变他们的生活。在大多数地方，这都是很难推销的。但这个城市已经绝望了。有时这就是事情发生改变所需要的。
Joe Richmond. He runs the Radio Diaries podcast, which this week has a story about a different guy who was in the ONS program. A guy who was shot 22 times. That's at radiodiaries.org or wherever you get your podcasts.
乔·里奇曼。他负责《广播日记》（Radio Diaries）播客，本周有一个关于ONS项目中另一个人的故事。一个被射中22枪的家伙。请访问radiodiaries.org或您获取播客的任何地方。
Act Three, Glacial Change. So far today on our show we've had opinion. We've had criminal behavior. And now we move to a third thing that can be notoriously difficult to change. And that is the mood of an unhappy teenager. Miki Meek explains.
第三幕，冰川般的改变（Glacial Change）。到目前为止，我们今天节目中已经谈到了观点。已经谈到了犯罪行为。现在我们转向第三个众所周知极难改变的事物。那就是不开心青少年的情绪。米基·米克（Miki Meek）为您解释。
When Zalena Su'e was 15, this is what her life was like. Her family lived in a beach house on an island in the South Pacific. And there were these bright green trees growing in her yard. They're called breadfruit trees. It was pretty dreamy.
当扎琳娜·苏（Zalena Su'e）15岁时，她的生活是这样的。她的家庭住在南太平洋一个岛上的海滨小屋里。院子里长着明亮的绿树。它们被称为面包果树。那相当梦幻。
It was literally my house, and then the road, and then the ocean. That was it.
那真的是我的房子，然后是路，然后是海洋。就是这样。
Really?
真的吗？
Yeah. Imagine the most beautiful mountains there and the sun sinking between those mountains. That was my view every single day. Just super easy to recognize paradise.
是的。想象一下那里最美丽的群山，太阳在群山之间沉没。那是我每天的风景。超级容易认出的天堂。
This was American Samoa, a US territory in Polynesia. Zalena had a tight-knit group of friends who all went to the same big public high school known for its champion football team, the Tafuna Warriors. They went to games and hung out in the bleachers and talked endlessly about their lives. She was also surrounded by tons of family-- aunts, uncles, and cousins. And on top of that was her church. She loved singing with them.
这就是美属萨摩亚（American Samoa），位于波利尼西亚的美国领地。扎琳娜有一群亲密的朋友，他们都去同一所因其冠军橄榄球队“塔福纳勇士队”（Tafuna Warriors）而闻名的大型公立高中。他们去看比赛，在看台上闲逛，没完没了地谈论他们的生活。她也被大量的家人包围——阿姨、叔叔和表亲们。除此之外还有她的教会。她喜欢和他们一起唱歌。
But then one day about two years ago, this all changed.
但大约两年前的一天，这一切都改变了。
My dad's just like, "I think God's calling us to go to Alaska." I'm like, where? [LAUGHS] What? That's not in my vocabulary. What? And he just said, "Whittier, Alaska."
我爸爸只是说：“我想上帝召唤我们要去阿拉斯加。”我心想，去哪儿？（笑）什么？那不在我的词汇里。什么？他只是说，“阿拉斯加惠蒂尔（Whittier）。”
What had happened was their pastor had sent out an email looking for someone to lead a new branch of their Baptist Church-- in, yes, Alaska.
发生的事情是他们的牧师发了一封电子邮件，寻找能带领他们浸信会新分支的人——没错，就在阿拉斯加。
I saw igloos. And I thought penguins were everywhere. I thought polar bears were walking down the street. I just saw frozen wasteland. That's it. No. No, no. We thought it was a joke. But apparently he'd sent in an email, he's like, "Put me on the waitlist." And our senior pastor's like, "There is no waiting list. And I think you're perfect."
我看到了冰屋。我想企鹅到处都是。我想北极熊在街上走。我看到的只是冰冻的荒原。就是这样。不。不，不。我们以为这是个笑话。但显然他发了封邮件，他说：“把我放在候补名单上。”我们的高级牧师说：“没有候补名单。我觉得你很完美。”
Not that her dad had ever started a church or been a pastor. He was a high school science teacher. And until now, no one in Zalena's family-- not her mom, not her three younger siblings-- had any idea that this was a dream of his.
并不是说她爸爸曾经建立过教会或当过牧师。他是一名高中科学老师。直到现在，扎琳娜家没人——不是她妈妈，也不是她三个年幼的弟弟妹妹——知道这是他的梦想。
Oh, yes. They complained a lot. But this is something that I really want to do a long time ago. This is my chance.
噢，是的。他们抱怨了很多。但这是我很久以前就想做的事情。这是我的机会。
This is your chance?
这是你的机会？
Yeah. To do God's work.
是的。做上帝的工作。
For her father, this wasn't a decision to make. It was a calling. At church, they often heard the phrase, "walk by faith and not by sight." And that is quite literally what they did. They sold all their belongings and used all of their savings on the move, including what they'd put away for Zalena to go to college. Then they got on a plane with two suitcases each and headed north without knowing a thing about where they were going. No one in the family even Googled the town to take a look at what they were getting into.
对于她父亲来说，这不是一个需要做出的决定。这是一个召唤。在教会，他们经常听到“凭信心行事，而不是凭眼见”这句话。而这实际上就是他们所做的。他们卖掉了所有财物，用光了所有积蓄去搬家，包括他们为扎琳娜上大学准备的钱。然后他们带着每个人两个行李箱上了飞机，北上，对要去的地方一无所知。家里甚至没有人谷歌过这个城镇，看看他们要卷入什么事情。
21 hours later, Zalena and her family landed in Anchorage, where a senior pastor running a Samoan church there picked them up. To get to Whittier from Anchorage, you go south about 60 miles and then you hit a mountain with a 2 and 1/2 mile tunnel. It's dark and narrow and shuts down at night. Zalena felt nervous and claustrophobic. But she also tried to be optimistic.
21小时后，扎琳娜和家人降落在安克雷奇（Anchorage），在那里，一位运营当地萨摩亚教会的高级牧师接了他们。要从安克雷奇去惠蒂尔，你需要向南走约60英里，然后你会遇到一座山，上面有一条2.5英里的隧道。它狭窄阴暗，晚上会关闭。扎琳娜感到紧张和幽闭恐惧。但她也努力保持乐观。
And then we came to the tunnel, and it was like, boom. Gloomy clouds and it's super dark. It looked like something out of one of those horror shows. Rain was just falling.
然后我们来到了隧道，就像，轰。阴沉的云层，非常黑。看起来像恐怖秀里的东西。雨一直在下。
Did you say out of a horror show?
你说像是恐怖秀？
Yes. It was terrible. And I just saw this huge building. 15 stories. So our senior pastor was like, "Everybody lives in here, by the way."
是的。那太可怕了。我只看到了这栋巨大的建筑。15层楼。所以我们的高级牧师说，“顺便提一下，每个人都住在这里。”
By that, he meant the whole town lived in that one building-- almost all of its 200 residents. Post office, stores, all in that one building.
他的意思是整个城镇都住在那一栋建筑里——几乎所有200名居民。邮局、商店，全在那一栋楼里。
And I was freaking out on the inside, thinking, "This is where I'm supposed to be?" And I cried.
我内心在抓狂，心想，“这就是我该待的地方？”然后我哭了。
To be technical about it, there are actually a few things outside the one big building. There's a school right behind it, which kids get to through an underground tunnel in the winter. There's one bar, an inn, and a convenience store. And there are parking lots filled with old fishing boats. But that's about it. Everything else takes place inside the building, a pink and tan relic of the Cold War.
严格来说，大楼外面确实有一些东西。大楼后面有一所学校，冬天孩子们通过一条地下隧道去那里。有一家酒吧、一家旅馆和一家便利店。还有装满了旧渔船的停车场。但仅此而已。其他所有事情都在大楼内进行，那是一个冷战时期的粉红色和棕褐色遗迹。
It used to house soldiers. The US Army actually picked Whittier as a port in the 1940s because the weather sucked so badly. There's so much cloud cover there that it was good for hiding ships and ammunition from enemy planes. But when the military pulled out, civilians started moving in. And soon, the building was filled with retirees.
它过去是给士兵住的。美国陆军实际上在1940年代选择惠蒂尔作为港口，因为天气实在是太糟糕了。那里有太多的云层覆盖，这对于隐藏敌机下的船只和弹药来说非常有利。但当军队撤出后，平民开始迁入。不久，这栋楼就住满了退休人员。
That's the post office.
那是邮局。
Zalena gave me tour down a dimly lit hallway with linoleum floors and brick walls painted off-white.
扎琳娜带我穿过一条灯光昏暗、铺着油毡地板、砖墙刷成灰白色的走廊。
This is the Whittier city officia. So this is like, mayor--
这是惠蒂尔市政厅。所以这是，市长——
We're on the first floor, which has the police station, laundromat, a tiny grocery store called Kozy Korner, a notary. This is Whittier's version of Main Street. The rest of the floors in the building are all residential.
我们在底楼，那里有警察局、自助洗衣店、一家叫Kozy Korner的小杂货店、一位公证人。这就是惠蒂尔版的“主街”。大楼里的其余楼层都是住宅。
Do different floors have different reputations?
不同楼层有不同的名声吗？
I think so. The sixth floor, we're pretty loud. And then certain floors are like old people floors where only old people live.
我想是的。六楼，我们这里挺吵的。然后某些楼层是“老人楼”，只有老年人住。
I asked her to take me to the top floor of the building.
我让她带我去大楼的最顶层。
I feel like it's mostly  rich people who live up here. It has a lot of really nice apartments up here. Like you have a sauna in your living room.
我觉得住在这里的大多是富人。这里有很多很棒的公寓。比如你在客厅里就有桑拿房。
You wouldn't know that this was the rich floor. It's pretty standard-- carpeted floors and green doors with numbers.
你不会知道这是富人区。它很普通——铺着地毯的楼层和标着数字的绿色门。
We went to the 14th floor. There's no 13th floor, so straight to the 12th. They all look the same.
我们去了14楼。没有13楼，所以直接去了12楼。它们看起来都一样。
What if I made you do this on every floor?
如果我让你在每一层楼都这么做呢？
It's gonna be the same view.
风景都一样。
I hope you don't mind that. [LAUGHS]
希望你不介意。（笑）
During her first few months in Alaska, Zalena tried to pretend that she wasn't really there. She only listened to Samoan music and ate Samoan food. Sometimes she even wore her old school uniform, a maroon sarong. She started shutting herself in her room and made a point of calling Samoa at least three times a day.
在阿拉斯加的头几个月里，扎琳娜试图假装自己并没有真正待在那里。她只听萨摩亚音乐，吃萨摩亚食物。有时她甚至穿着她的旧校服，一条栗色的纱笼。她开始把自己关在房间里，每天至少给萨摩亚打三次电话。
I would not go to bed without Skyping somebody back home. It was pretty bad. But it's true. And so I'd go to sleep thinking I'm in Samoa. And I'd wake up be like, [SIGH] I have to go through another day of this.
不Skype回老家，我就不会上床睡觉。那真的很糟糕。但这是真的。所以我睡觉时想着我在萨摩亚。醒来时就会想，（叹气）我必须再过一天这样的日子。
And this is?
而这就是？
And this is like being dropped on Mars. And you're looking for water. It's  like, "What? How can I survive here?"
就像被丢到了火星。你在找水。感觉就像，“什么？我怎么能在这里生存？”
All six people in Zalena's family were crammed into a tiny apartment in Whittier. She shared a bed with her nine-year-old sister, Mona, and she could hear her neighbors' conversations through the walls.
扎琳娜家里所有六个人都被挤进了惠蒂尔的一间小公寓里。她和九岁的妹妹莫娜（Mona）共用一张床，她能隔着墙听到邻居的谈话。
There were a handful of families in the building from places like the Philippines and Guam. But their kids were much younger than Zalena. There was another girl her age, too, but when Zalena tried introducing herself, the girl blew her off. So Zalena did what a lot of teenagers might do. She shut down.
大楼里有少数来自菲律宾和关岛之类的家庭。但他们的孩子比扎琳娜小得多。也有另一个和她同龄的女孩，但当扎琳娜试图自我介绍时，那个女孩对她不理不睬。所以扎琳娜做了很多青少年可能会做的事情。她封闭了自己。
Meanwhile, once her family got to Alaska, they found out that they'd moved halfway across the world to start a church for only three Samoan families. Zalena's dad was unfazed. He'd been a high school science teacher. But now he got a job doing manual labor in the harbor and used the money to support his family and the new church.
与此同时，她的家人搬到阿拉斯加后，发现他们搬到了世界另一端，竟然是为了仅仅三个萨摩亚家庭建立教会。扎琳娜的父亲对此毫不动摇。他曾是高中科学老师。但现在他找到了一份在港口做体力活的工作，并用这笔钱来供养家庭和新教会。
The church is in a windowless room in the basement of the building. On Sundays, Zalena's dad projects a pink and red sunset onto a concrete wall. Everyone in the congregation dresses in bright floral prints, sarongs, and flip flops. The best way I can describe it is that it's kind of like tropical Christian karaoke.
教会位于大楼地下室一个没有窗户的房间里。周日，扎琳娜的父亲把粉红色和红色的日落投影到混凝土墙上。会众里的每个人都穿着鲜艳的花卉印花服装、纱笼和人字拖。我能描述的最好方式是，它有点像热带基督教卡拉OK。
Church was the one thing that Zalena actually looked forward to. Other than that, she rarely left the apartment-- much less the building-- for months, despite her parents' attempts to get her out.
教会是扎琳娜真正期待的一件事。除此之外，尽管父母想方设法让她出门，但在接下来的几个月里，她几乎从未离开过公寓——更别提离开这栋楼了。
I don't see the draw to leaving my house. The only place that the kids were playing in was the basement. There's no place to go.
我不觉得离开我的房子有什么吸引力。孩子们玩耍的唯一地方是地下室。没地方去。
What do you mean, the basement?
你是什么意思，地下室？
Cause it rains a lot. So they can't go outside to go play. And so they were playing tag in the basement, which is full of cages, like storage cages. But it looks like a prison down there. And they go play cops and robbers and they think it's fun, and running around. And I'm just like, this is pretty depressing.
因为雨下得很大。所以他们不能去外面玩。所以他们在地下室玩捉人游戏，那里全是笼子，像是储藏笼。但那里看起来像监狱。他们去玩警察抓小偷，他们觉得很有趣，跑来跑去。我只是心想，这挺令人沮丧的。
For the younger kids, living in the building was like living in one big never ending slumber party. They ran up and down the halls and sang songs in the elevator and took over the lobby after dinner to play games. And because the school's so small, just 35 students, a bunch of them were also in Zalena's classroom.
对于年幼的孩子来说，住在这栋楼里就像住进了一场永无止境的超大睡衣派对。他们在走廊里跑来跑去，在电梯里唱歌，晚饭后占领大厅玩游戏。而且因为学校很小，只有35名学生，其中很多也在扎琳娜的教室里。
I was really bummed out, because I was like, oh my gosh. I was looking for the whole senior shebang. Everybody talks about prom, homecoming, football teams, and all these things. And I went to schools that had those. And now I'm here, and it's just like-- I am a senior. I'm a senior. And I'm in the same classroom with a seventh grader.
我真的很失落，因为我心想，天哪。我本来期待着高中毕业的全套流程。每个人都在谈论毕业舞会、返校节、橄榄球队，所有这些事情。我以前去的学校有这些。而现在我在这一里，就像——我是一个高三学生。我是一个高三学生。而我和一个七年级的学生在同一个教室里。
To make it even worse, one of those seventh graders ended up being Zalena's youngest brother, Philip, who knew exactly how to get on her nerves.
更糟糕的是，其中一个七年级学生竟然是扎琳娜最小的弟弟菲利普（Philip），他非常清楚怎么让她心烦。
I would tap on the desk. And she would get mad. I would sing out loud and she would get mad.
我会敲桌子。她就会生气。我会大声唱歌，她就会生气。
So what would she say to you?
那她会对你说什么？
She(SUBJE said, "Stop it." And I would say, "You're not the boss." And she hates that.
她说，“停下来。”然后我会说，“你又不是老板。”她最讨厌那个。
Until very recently, this was Zalena's life in Whittier. And then she hit a point where she knew that if something was going to change, it wouldn't be Whittier. It had to be her. So she started forcing herself to be more social. When she had to share an elevator with a stranger, she'd smile big and say hello. But what really turned things for her in Whittier all came down to this one day.
直到最近，这就是扎琳娜在惠蒂尔的生活。然后她到了一个临界点，她知道如果有什么要改变，那不会是惠蒂尔。那必须是她自己。所以她开始强迫自己变得更社交。当她不得不和陌生人共享电梯时，她会露出大大的笑容并问好。但在惠蒂尔改变她生活的一切都归结于这一天。
This is February 24. So that was like our first official "Hey, let's go walk your dog."
那是2月24日。那是我们第一个正式的“嘿，我们去遛狗吧”。
The girl who had blown her off when she first moved in-- her name is Sofia-- actually invited Zalena out. They walked down to the ocean with Sofia's dog. Zalena showed me a picture from that day.
刚搬进来时对她不理不睬的那个女孩——她的名字叫索菲亚（Sofia）——实际上邀请了扎琳娜出去。她们带着索菲亚的狗走到了海边。扎琳娜给我看了那天的一张照片。
So it was funny, cause it was like, "Let's take a silly picture" or something like that. "We need a senior picture." And so she jumped onto the rock next to me and she hooked her left arm over my shoulder. And I was like, "Aw." And in the middle of me exclaiming "aw," somebody took the picture. And so my mouth is open, and we're both smiling.
那很有趣，因为就像，“让我们拍张傻傻的照片”什么的。“我们需要一张高三照片。”所以她跳到我旁边的石头上，把左胳膊搭在我的肩膀上。我就像，“啊。”就在我惊呼“啊”的时候，有人拍了那张照片。所以我的嘴是张着的，我们俩都在笑。
This happened three weeks before I met Zalena. Since that day, Zalena's been outside the building more times than she had been in months. One day Sofia showed her a favorite secret spot out in the forest. They walked to where there was an old wooden plank in the ground, covered over with dirt and leaves. Sofia pulled up the plank, revealing an abandoned military tunnel. Zalena says it was awesome.
这发生在我认识扎琳娜的三周前。从那天起，扎琳娜出门的次数比过去几个月加起来还要多。有一天，索菲亚向她展示了森林里的一个最爱的秘密地点。她们走到那里，有一块废弃的旧木板在地里，上面覆盖着泥土和树叶。索菲亚掀起木板，露出了一个被废弃的军事隧道。扎琳娜说那棒极了。
There was like a sisterhood going on right there. Sometimes I feel like a fan girl of hers, cause I'm always just like, "Sofia!" She's my best friend. She hasn't really claimed our best friendship yet, but she knows.
那里就像有一种姐妹情谊在萌芽。有时我觉得自己像她的粉丝，因为我总是，“索菲亚！”她是我的闺蜜。她还没有真正认领我们的闺蜜关系，但她心里知道。
I was thinking about that, too.
我也在想那个。
Here's Sofia. She moved to Whittier from the Philippines about four years ago. Before Zalena moved in, she had been the only kid in her grade.
这是索菲亚。她四年前从菲律宾搬到惠蒂尔。在扎琳娜搬进来之前，她是她们年级唯一的孩子。
Sometimes I feel bad that Zalena always says that I'm her best friend. But then I never actually say that Zalena's my best friend.
有时我觉得很抱歉，扎琳娜总是说我是她的闺蜜。但我从没真正说过扎琳娜是我的闺蜜。
Why not?
为什么不呢？
I feel like it's awkward.
我觉得那有点尴尬。
Is she your best friend?
她是你的闺蜜吗？
She is.
她是。
Are you gonna tell her?
你要告诉她吗？
Yeah. Maybe tomorrow at school.
是的。也许明天在学校。
After finding this one friend, the one great friend, Zalena stopped seeing Whittier as this gloomy place she couldn't escape from and now described it as--
在找到这一个朋友，这一个好朋友之后，扎琳娜不再把惠蒂尔视为她无法逃离的阴郁之地，现在她形容它为——
Now I would say enclosed serenity.
现在我会说是“封闭的宁静”。
Zalena can now list off dozens of things that are great about Whittier. And a lot of them are the exact things she used to hate about the place.
扎琳娜现在可以列举出几十件关于惠蒂尔很棒的事情。而且很多都是她曾经讨厌这个地方的正是那些点。
Everything's in one building. There's just that kind of intimacy where you can go to someone's house and just start cooking. And the mountains-- they're very flawlessly cut, I'd say. They're like diamonds.
一切都在一栋楼里。有一种亲密感，你可以去某人家里，就开始做饭。还有山——它们切得非常完美，我会说。它们像钻石一样。
Before, you would have looked at them as like--
以前，你可能看着它们会觉得——
Before, I would have looked at them as like, "Ew." Because the mountains back home have trees on everything. It's green. But Alaska's beautiful. It's rugged, raw beauty here.
以前，我看着它们会觉得，“呃。”因为老家的山上到处都有树。那是绿色的。但阿拉斯加很美。这里有粗犷、原始的美。
It was kind of like I tripped and then, boom-- fell in love with Whittier. [LAUGHS] And I don't even know how to explain it.
感觉就像是我跌倒了，然后，轰——爱上了惠蒂尔。（笑）我甚至不知道该怎么解释。
OK, so how would you have rated Whittier when you first got here?
好的，那么你刚来这里时会给惠蒂尔打几分？
Out of niceness, I would have given it a four out of 10.
出于礼貌，我会给它打4分（10分制）。
And what would you give it now?
那你现在会给它打几分？
Probably an 11. Or maybe a 10 on the bad days.
可能是11分。或者在糟糕的日子里可能是10分。
It blows my mind how much you've changed since you first got here. Because I feel like it can take people a long time to get to that spot or they never get to that spot of liking something or deciding to like something.
自从你刚来这里，你改变了这么多，这真让我大吃一惊。因为我觉得人们可能需要很长时间才能到达那个阶段，或者他们永远到不了那个喜欢上某件事或决定去喜欢某件事的阶段。
Yeah. I feel like I've changed so much. I'm pretty proud of myself for accepting, for getting over it. For getting over the change. I hope that my college is something like Whittier, because I would get around so well.
是的。我觉得我改变了这么多。我很为自己感到骄傲，能够接受，能够走出来。克服了这种改变。我希望我的大学生活能像惠蒂尔一样，因为那样我会适应得很好。
There's a thing adults tell kids all the time, especially teenagers-- you make your own happiness. It's all about your outlook on things. It's such an irritating cliche. But sometimes it's true.
有一件事大人们一直告诉孩子，特别是青少年——你创造你自己的快乐。这完全取决于你对待事物的眼光。这是一种非常恼人的陈词滥调。但有时它是真的。
Miki Meek is one of the producers of our program.
米基·米克是我们节目的制作者之一。
Our program was produced today by Stephanie Foo with Zoe Chace, Sean Cole, Chana Joffe-Walt, Miki Meek, Jonathan Menjivar, Brian Reed, Robyn Semien, Alissa Shipp, and Nancy Updike. Our senior producer is Julie Snyder. Editing help from Joel Lovell and production help from Simon Adler. Seth Lind is our operations director. Emily Condon's our production manager. Elise Bergerson's our office manager. Elna Baker scouts stories for our show.
我们今天的节目由斯蒂芬妮·福（Stephanie Foo）制作，佐伊·蔡斯（Zoe Chace）、肖恩·科尔（Sean Cole）、查娜·乔菲-沃尔特（Chana Joffe-Walt）、米基·米克、乔纳森·门吉瓦（Jonathan Menjivar）、布莱恩·里德（Brian Reed）、罗宾·塞米恩（Robyn Semien）、艾丽莎·希普（Alissa Shipp）和南希·厄普戴克（Nancy Updike）共同参与。我们的高级制片人是朱莉·斯奈德（Julie Snyder）。编辑协助来自乔尔·洛维尔（Joel Lovell），制作协助来自西蒙·阿德勒（Simon Adler）。赛斯·林德（Seth Lind）是我们的运营总监。艾米丽·康登（Emily Condon）是我们的制作经理。埃莉斯·伯格森（Elise Bergerson）是我们的办公室经理。埃尔娜·贝克（Elna Baker）为我们的节目搜寻故事。
Research help today from Michelle Harris and Christopher Swetala. Music help from Damien Graef and Rob Geddis. Special thanks today to Erika Thompson, Kelly Bender, Jason Reifler, Brendan Nyhan, Robert Cialdini, Gus Levine, and Mark Phillips.
研究协助来自米歇尔·哈里斯（Michelle Harris）和克里斯托弗·斯韦塔拉（Christopher Swetala）。音乐协助来自达米安·格拉夫（Damien Graef）和罗伯·格迪斯（Rob Geddis）。特别感谢今天埃里卡·汤普森（Erika Thompson）、凯利·本德（Kelly Bender）、杰森·雷夫勒（Jason Reifler）、布兰登·尼汉（Brendan Nyhan）、罗伯特·恰尔迪尼（Robert Cialdini）、格斯·莱文（Gus Levine）和马克·菲利普斯（Mark Phillips）。
Our website, thisamericanlife.org.
我们的网站，thisamericanlife.org。
This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange.
《美国生活》由公共广播交换中心（PRX）分发给公共广播电台。
Thanks, as always, to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia. He was doing yoga for a while to relax, but it was not working.
像往常一样，感谢我们节目的联合创始人，托里·马拉蒂亚（Torey Malatia）先生。他有一段时间在做瑜伽来放松，但这并不奏效。
I'm not doing that no more. What I'm doing is marijuana.
我再也不做那些了。我做的是大麻。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life .
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带回更多《美国生活》的故事。